so without further
do let me get started and let's see and
so we'll ask the question why study
African cities or but first of all this
is an image of the town that I live in
when I excavate the ancient site of
Jenny so this is a site of of Jenny it's
got about twenty thousand people when
you see the archeological sites in this
area that are classic tells like the
tells in Mesopotamia imagine that this
is what it would have looked like this
is the mosque at Jenny is the largest
used Adobe structure in the world - in
the world today so it very much gives
you an image of what some of these
cities may have looked like but why do I
say why study African cities or and
that's because I'm going to put the
frame this in terms of what should my
ex-graduate student-- mama Dulce say do
when he excavates a seat
now mama do has or C say we call him has
a problem and that is that he's been
working for about ten years they did his
dissertation on a town called Gao hidden
French it's gone see an ancient ancient
cattle it's not on your your your
handout I'll show you where that is but
it's a big problem because at this point
he's excavated about ten hectares so
that's twenty Eve 24 acres all of all
architecture you can see some of that in
the back he worked for with with me for
about twenty years as as my one of my
supervisors that but at the the the site
of Jenny and that's the image you see
there but we have no idea that we had no
idea that the city was there that
radiocarbon dates are coming out four
hundred to about 900 AD now we knew that
Gao was a capital of one of the major
so-called medieval West African empires
the Empire of
songhai from about the 15th century we
had no idea that there was a large city
everywhere we go either excavating see
say excavate
or using ground-penetrating radar we're
finding the same massive massive
structures so I'm going to frame this
talk in terms of three things that Cisse
needs to do or needs to think about as
he continues his studies he's now the
second-in-command of the heritage
ministry in the in the in in Mali in his
home country so he is really in charge
of all of the archaeology being done in
that country that has some of the
earliest and most original urbanism in
sub-saharan Africa so here's the
position of Gao it's it's so you can
locate it on your on your handout so one
question is how should see say excavate
what we're going to be calling a an
assembled City a shorter way to talk
about that is how should see say dig
when he's dealing with a city like that
has no reference at all in history we
have no it and really doesn't look like
any of the other towns in the in the
country that we've been excavating how
does he just on a practical basis how
does he proceed with the excavation
second question can you ignore the rural
neighbors so although you Dow on CN is
in the modern town of Dow as you go down
the Niger River there are large tells
and large scatters this happens to just
be a scatter but this was an ancient
settlement probably lasted about 500
years I'm going to estimate that we've
got about three or four meters of
deposits there but it's very close I
mean he was literally in some of these
cases it's spitting distance from each
of these settlements again we had no no
inkling that that that this wealth of
settlements was along the Niger River
so in order to answer that question in a
more abbreviated form can he ignore the
rural native neighbors how should see
say look at the
these hinterland and finally what's the
equation of CeeCee's massive structure
with what we had always thought and
certainly when I started out in the mid
70s
in in West Africa we thought there
should be some kind of a state I just if
it's not a despotic state but some kind
of a hierarchical organization of Labor
and of and a fan of people behind the
the foundation of a of the city so we
have three three questions then how
should she say shake off the dead hand
of old theory I'm giving myself the way
in that in that case how should he look
at the the hinterland and how should he
dig so let's go let's go through so
there was a time and that's breaking
down but it's still still there in the
back back of the lines of most
archaeologists that a despotic state is
coincident with if not a prerequisite
for urbanism and that's something that's
breaking down in the near East as well
as many other places but I'll just make
the assertion that it's because of this
idea that we have this this presumption
that it's really most interesting to
excavate original urban situations in
other words where you find city where in
the world you find cities without
influence from other urban situations in
some ways it's lesser in some ways it's
not as interesting for archaeologists to
work on places that had demonstrable
evidence of influence from the outside
the effect of that is about 90% of the
Earth's surface was ignored by classical
urban archaeologists like myself because
there was no written record of contact
with these other areas so it's now that
places like Southeast Asia
now that the slip side of the Amazon the
of the Andes the Amazonian side of the
Andes now the sub-saharan Africa is open
to a different kind of archaeologists
that we're finding a greater diversity
of cities again without any evidence of
contact from from the the
well-established six original cores of
urbanism we'll come to that in yet so
cities were supposed to in their layout
in the the material culture in the end
the ARCA truck the architecture in some
way reflect the hierarchical structure
of society and also the hierarchical
hierarchical distribution of power I
gave you two readings to read in advance
and certainly the one by Carlos anomaly
and and and myself emphasizes the power
presumptions of urbanism I'm not really
going to talk about that too much except
to say that this is a classic depiction
of a hierarchy with the chief for King
on top with a with an elite the elite
have a function of distributing the
decisions of the king down through the
populace and they act as gatekeepers
keeping information irrelevant
information if you will from going from
the from the base up to the object up to
the top but there was always a
presumption by urban archaeologists like
myself that you would find architectural
reflections of this structure in the
city and it may not surprise you that
generations of urban archaeologists were
more interested in the seats or the
Citadel's of the Kings or the that or
that or the Chiefs and until recently
less interested in the diversity of the
pop of the population so we look for
things like monuments religious
monuments we look for things like city
walls as as as reflections of the of the
power structure of the of the town but
what if you have situations and we know
we have many many many in the world now
what if you had a situation where even
if there was a king and the king may be
very very hard to find that the classic
despotic hierarchical organization is
maybe evident maybe it was never really
relevant to the founding of the of the
city or the functioning of the of the
city so I'm going to over and over come
to tell Brock it's in some cases spelled
B RAK but it's one of these classic
cities in northern Syria that has
several generations of archaeologists
thinking in different ways about talib
rock started with excavation so I served
max max mallow in in the 20s I believe a
very traditional approach to tell Brock
continuing excavations by Joan and David
Oates at Cambridge and this is why I
call Cal rock with a C rather than a K
because they insisted on on spelling it
that way
but they were kind of in a transition
they started their careers as
traditional urban Mesopotamian
archaeologists and yet as time went on
over their long career at Cambridge in
their long career of excavating or
thinking about being exposed to non
traditional non despotic cities they
started to think about it in a different
way and I'll be ending up and talking
about how some of the work from the
assembled or clustered cities in West
Africa have have conversations with
myself and and others with the present
excavator who's Jason or at Harvard has
a has changed his approach to looking at
the city looking at the founding of the
city and we have a different very
different tell Brock now because because
of that but let me show you our first
African city which is great zimbabwe and
probably everyone here has some
familiarity with great zimbabwe and the
ideology behind great zimbabwe but it
was certainly was the case that right
from the very beginning when the
butchers who excavated the the site
first and I really shouldn't reward
their efforts with with they were
basically mining the the site for gold
there wasn't much gold but
by the time the first legitimate
archaeologist gets to the site who is
gay Gertrude King Thompson in 1928 there
were no deposits left anywhere in the in
the big structure of Great Zimbabwe
so she was reduced to looking at the
spoils heap so as you go through the
material you make great big mounds of
inverted materials in other words the
older stuff is up on the top so she
would go through she reconstructed
what's pretty close to the what we know
now is the true story of Great Zimbabwe
doing the reverse reverse stratigraphy
but right from the very beginning the
excavators who were part of the colonial
administration in what was then southern
Zimbabwe had a problem this looked like
it should be the capital of a king but
it was part of the colonial ideology
that there shouldn't have been Kings at
the time so there was all this neat
nonsense about this being a trading
outpost of the Queen of Sheba and the
Phoenicians Kings came down here and had
hived off empires and whatnot it was
very clear from the pottery which is
very similar to the present-day Shona
the pottery of the present-day Shona
period that this was all nonsense but
this was a major part of of the of the
idea but continuing now that we
understand more about Great Zimbabwe and
about his founding in the middle of the
13th century there was still the idea
that there had to have been a developed
state if not despotic then some kind of
a of an elite that the architecture of
Great Zimbabwe whether the fine whether
the hilltop enclosure which is supposed
to be where the king in the Western
close enclosure and the Queen and the
eastern exposure or in the great
enclosure down so this is a view of the
great enclosure from the hill from the
hilltop
if early archaeologists couldn't just
couldn't make make sense of the great
enclosure clearly monumental
architecture we now believe that it's a
place for initiation rituals for for
kids coming in from communities from the
vast area in present-day and Zimbabwe
but there was still this idea that it
really should reflect some kind of a
hierarchical state organization now this
is innocent pity area when in 2001 I was
brought in to Pretoria University of
Pretoria which was the trademark
apartheid University in South Africa the
archaeology department was a was a mess
and I was its Pope in academic terms
it's called they're taking a department
into receivership so my first year I had
to fire all of the the staff the second
year I had to read rehire staff my first
hire was the professor or the yeah the
the head of head of department which is
innocent picker area now innocent wrote
the book on the ground grain at Great
Zimbabwe society he is Zimbabwean
himself which means there's a little bit
of tension between himself and the South
African and the black South African
elites so innocent is in the position of
trying to kind of pull back on this idea
that great zimbabwe and another site
i'll show you in a moment were
reflections of a fully established state
the problem with that is that it's part
of the ideology of the anc that Great
Zimbabwe and the earlier site Maupin
good way
we're capitals of the state and so
they've got a black Zimbabwean pulling
back on what is now SATA state ideology
it gets a little more complicated
so here's great great zimbabwe here in
the middle of sim bob way right on the
Limpopo River which is where I do it
a lot of my work there's a number of
complicated sites complex sites
especially this one this is my own group
way the the state ideology now in South
Africa is that Maupin groobly was the
seat of the first state in sub-saharan
Africa and here you see the excavations
from the University of Pretoria in the
20s of a number of so-called royal
burials individuals probably high status
individuals we can tell from their
health but also they had tens hundreds
of thousands of gold beads trade items
coming in from the from the Swahili
Swahili coast and then the presumption
was that the the commoners lived at the
declining status away from the from the
the Citadel it itself well when those
excavations started it was clear that
there were there was no correlation at
all between spatial distance from the
from the from the the Citadel and the
status it seems to be that the the
plateau was surrounded by different
craft organizations graph craftsmen so
you have as ceramicists you have iron
workers living in different quarters if
if you will this will become a pattern
that's very very familiar now I just
wanted to emphasize how really fought
this is this is the classic illustration
of the ideology of archaeology as taught
in Pretoria one of the Afrikaner
universities why the department was in
such a mess with a with the ending of
Pretoria that basically taught that when
the Dutch arrived at Cape Town in 1652
there were a number of bantu-speaking
tribes just waiting waiting that may
have been waiting there for centuries
just waiting to cross the Limpopo the
moment the Dutch put their foot on the
on the shore at Cape Town then they
start to move across the Limpopo
so by the time the divorce or the
Afrikaners reach this area as part of
the Great Trek in the 818 30:38 they had
really just come across the river they
hadn't established himself so in other
words Pretoria Johannesburg all this
area here the Durban and the whole of
the Cape was unoccupied territory now we
know archaeologically that's just
nonsense but that was that was the kind
of archaeology that was taught at
Pretoria and the secret government of
South Africa under apartheid was the
brood wound the the band of brothers the
the professor of archeology had a
permanent seat on the eighth member the
brooder brooder boat so important was
the archeology to the to the ideology of
apartheid so I mean obviously things
have things things have changed and
renewed excavations that pipe places
like mouth and roadway and a number of
other satellite sites are part of
rewriting this whole idea and despotism
doesn't really seem to have much of a
much of a role in our new understanding
just another example of the if you will
be the tyranny of this kind of idea this
is a largest reconstruction of Memphis
many not all but many Egyptologist
apologists are calling cities like
Memphis theatre cities basically saying
that for most of the year there are very
few people at Memphis the town would
fill up like a bellows at ceremonial
moments the this was a theatre this was
a stage for these for the for the
processions and whatnot and then people
would leave for there particularly for
the agricultural season well that may be
the case but when archaeologists in the
turn of the century return of the 20th
century and through most of the 20th
century went down the river down to the
south into what now is the Sudan
Republic
they found sites that really didn't fit
their their conception of what was going
on when one is karma
so the first George Reisner the first
excavator saw the big structure and what
we call the de FIFA thought it was a
pyramid excavated as it as it was a
pyramid I don't really know that there's
anything left for excavators because of
the kind of the butchery and actually
George Reisner was a very very good
archeologist for the for the time but
there was a series of structures all
around clearly a town very large large
area he just couldn't deal with with it
it looked like an African village or a
thousand African villages just plopped
next to this this this structure now he
George Reisner clearly thought that it
was the Egyptians who came in either
through diffusion of ideas or actual
colonists actual settlers who created
something that looked like their
pyramids and then perhaps that became a
an attraction and magnet point for for
for the for the local local people well
there have been 20 years now of
excavations by the Swift's and we now
have an idea that the de Fuko was some
kind of a religious structure there no
question about that but they are more
interested in the beginnings from this
about 6000 BC to the heyday at about
3,000 BC of this this what would you
call it if you're thinking in terms of
despotic hierarchical organization this
is certainly not organized in a way that
you would you would imagine a sharper
neighs hypothesis and I can completely
agree with him is that this for some
reason for some religious reason that
goes back into the middle of the
Holocene was this an attractive point
for seasonally for different pastoral
clans to come to come when clans known
to the Egyptians as the sea sea and the
sea people not si but see the sea group
and they would come periodically
seasonally and this may have had a very
small population for part of the year
and a very large population seasonally
and this this assembled if you will
organization reflected what was what was
going on now we have a couple other
examples of that the claimed earlier
city in Peru on the west coast of Peru
just south of Lima is coral and this is
clearly massive amounts of labour went
into the into the construction of
Correll but as far as we know for most
of the year no more than about a hundred
people priests lived at Corel but for
the high ceremonial season thousands of
people came in they were organized not
by any despotic kind of king but by
their religious beliefs to keep adding
to this massive great great structure so
I think there's a better chance that
that chorale and the Peruvian analog is
the better explenation for what's going
on at kurma than the the old despotic
message so to get back to mama Dulce
saying how does how should see say shake
off the dead hand of old theory is the
city an artifact of the state
one more yeah okay lesson one
perhaps some work perhaps great zimbabwe
edits its heyday was the reflection of a
state but the majority of African cities
that we know now were not the seat of a
despotic ruler so if your excavation
techniques are driven by your assumption
that you'd have an hire a hierarchy of
architecture a hierarchy of material
culture reflecting the hierarchy of
power distribution in the town you've
clearly got to rethink your excavation
techniques in in this case so what
should see say do how should see say
excavate so we have this curious
structure at kurma but we have another
example later in time starting about in
the 15th century in Nigeria and Benin
City that I'll be talking about is just
one of many
we call it the Yerba model the
traditional Yerba model of cities but
but it was clearly has spread to many
other people
in something forested west africa than
than just the Yoruba so one of the
curious things about Benin City is that
we've always known that the and there
was a king in later times the King
compound was surrounded by these
enormous great walls and and ditches and
some of the first things the British did
when they conquered the city in the 880
1998 was trying to walk and map you know
the British being good surveyors tried
to map map this this structure so so
this is Benin City today named City
today a later archaeologist British
archaeologists at the end right at
independence mapped all of this he spent
his entire career just mapping this part
we now have
the same kind of cellular structure of
these great big ditches covering this
whole entire area here maybe 1/10 is
properly mapped so you can see a very 20
20 20 meters between 20 meters between
the the height of the bank and the and
the bottom of the of the of the ditch so
an enormous reserve of labour must have
gone into the into the building of this
only two parts of the wall have been
have been sectioned and none of the
sediments within the cellular structures
have been excavated at all so all of
that that effort by archaeologists just
to get a plan of the cellular structure
so if you remember the map of kurma how
it looked like a cluster or an
assemblage of different different about
different things this seems to be going
on a bit insidious as well very
different how however this is nip or
from the from the air very different
from our classic classic classic
Mesopotamian cities where you have a
city wall basically because of internal
internecine warfare between the cities
you had a more or less depopulated
hinterland we're at roar area between
and all the population is packed in in
designated places and the archaeologists
have tended to work on the religious
structures and the palatial structures
so in other words those parts of the
architecture and City Planning which
should reflect the higher end of the of
the of the hierarchy and that was very
much here's tell Brock again very much
the story of the excavations max Mallon
and then the Oates's of Cal Brock we're
gonna see a very very different tell
Brock in just a little one but I wanted
to show you another one of these
assembled cities are clustered clustered
cities we don't really know if they're
cities they're certainly large enough to
be cities
probably had is hard to imagine on
analogy with pastoral people in the
Sahara and also in South Africa now that
some of these if all of these structures
were occupied and most of the space
would have been used for for cattle but
if all these structures were occupied
and you wouldn't have as many as 40,000
45,000 people at one at one point now
this is a part of Mauritania called
Titian it's a great big arcing
escarpment that surrounds an Old River
River an old massive massive lake and
this goes on you find these structures
for over 650 kilometres along the along
the escarpment so just a couple couple
of those images so this is this is the
escarpment around this old lake there's
Tish it gouge that we've talked about
and we're going to be coming back with
see a relationship between tisha and
Timbuktu and Jenny so it's the time when
the Sahara was was wet there were large
lakes Lake Chad which is the largest
lake now was 10 times the size over a
million square kilometers of surface
surface area this would have been the
lake here so this this this this this is
a little misleading but we're on the
lake here looking up at the escarpment
at the cliffs and all along the cliff
top and in some cases along the the the
slip slope of the you find these these
structures some of them are fairly
compact this may have had five hundred
people a thousand people with with many
many many many cattle some of them are
very long you're looking at about two
kilometers across here with large pens
for for cattle
okay and some of them are very are very
very large indeed this is what they
looked like on the ground so this is not
just a couple of rocks outlining the the
cattle cattle pens and the and and the
houses this would have represented an
enormous amount of labour so we think
this begins the excavation has been a
little bit spotty we think this begins
somewhere in the sixth millennium of BP
before the before the present and by
about a thousand BC it's it's basically
abandoned the lake the lake has dried
out and it's been it's been abandoned
now it's almost certain that this was
occupied by Posterous so it may have
been very similar to what we think is
going on at that Kerma
certain parts of the Year everybody the
whole community is reassembled at the
town and then other parts of the year at
least the young men go off with the
cattle in it was a very typical
transhuman system but even if all of
these ruins and we've we've documented
20 thousands of these in that arc of
over 600 kilometers even if they weren't
all occupied at the same time it still
represents an enormous population now
our analogy is from similar behavior
amongst pastoralists in east africa and
especially in south africa so some of
the work my students are doing my
Pretoria students are doing in South
Africa
is looking at structures now this
happens to be Shaka's enclosure at the
beginning of this career but it's
organized in a way the archaeology of
Jacques Corral and the earlier Corral is
clearly very similar to what we're
finding it at at at Titian
and these are some of my my students at
Pretoria all of whom are digging
different examples of these kinds of
enclosures so we started our Titian and
from their 600 kilometers down to their
the hundreds of these and I would just
if if you have nothing if you have
insomnia tonight go on Google Google
Earth fine Tish it you could find
there's a village of tissue about 200
people fine tissue and just follow that
arc and this is the sort of thing you'll
see this is a massive massive great one
close to some of my excavations in this
part of Mali
here's another long that's about four
kilometers so again as an archaeologist
the issue is we're all of these
compounds occupied at the same time or
did people come back year after year
occupying the same air general area but
it's it's the classic palimpsest problem
for for archaeologists and we won't know
that until there are lifetimes of
excavations by by young archaeologists
like like like see say but it leads that
phenomenon leads to Timbuktu the classic
Timbuktu Timbuktu itself as far as we
know is a fairly recent town probably
11th century maybe to some of you 11th
century is doesn't seem recent but but
compared to what we found in the
hinterland
so there's Timbuktu here here's the
Niger River and starting in the mid 80s
and then with my graduate students in
the 2007 we've done a number of surveys
of an old defunct waterway what's called
a Wadi that goes 300 kilometers up into
the Sarah so the from the wet period of
West African prehistory there are at
least a dozen of these waters going up
and they would have fed water from the
Niger or the Senegal River into these
massive Great Lakes of covering the
covering the Sahara but you can't walk
the banks of those bodies without
stepping on late Stone Age or Neolithic
and material or iron age material so
this is this is one of the sites that I
excavated there's
only 25 hectares so that's a 64 or so 8
acres a graduate student dug part looked
at this and I this is what this is one
this is actually one continuous site
it's been cut through by the by the
river actually grew up along the along
the river and Timbuktu is an area of
moving dunes so you have you come come
to the site site at one point and
there's clearly an archeological site
can be up to five meters high the next
season you come in and the wind has
blown over it and you can't find that
that that that part of the site but
after several season and a dissertation
of excavating so this is this is what
the site looked like with the Sahara off
to the side there's no rocks here so
this is all pottery so he's got a city
assembled out of different parts and
he's assemblies excavated and a number
of number of parts of that so it's
clearly an archaeological site with lots
of specialists particularly ceramic
specialists so he has a model that at a
time in the middle of the first
millennium BC when the waters were
higher at the high-water period
basically everyone either left
seasonally or they lived on the height
of the two highest parts so this would
be the light blue would be water level
four meters above where the highest that
it gets today but at low water which
would be two meters above where it gets
today people dispersed off into their
own individual communities and he's
finding communities of sheep and goat
herders distinct from the communities of
cattle herders distinct from the
meddlers metallurgists distinct from the
ceramicists so part of the year they're
living together but part of the year
they're dispersing off into these I like
the word assembled or clustered but
let's let's use the word assemble house
this is maybe what it look
like now in my article that I gave you I
gave you that quote from Richard Burton
they execute the Explorer of central
central Africa saying that these cities
in central Africa that were clearly
cities both in function and in size and
in population they're clearly cities but
to the untrained or the overly trained
European eye they look like a heap of
huts that was his classic quotes so -
Musa's which is what we're calling this
this town near near Timbuktu
looks like a heap of huts and yet it
function in size site with numbers of
people and in its relationship to the
hinterland and that's that's that's the
last part of of all this as as a true as
a true city certainly didn't look like a
European classic European or
Mesopotamian city so what is in assemble
city it's an evolving functioning mosaic
of purposes I think that's what's going
on certainly with Benin City and all
those other Yerba Europa cities we would
love to know what was going on in the
12th century so there's oral traditions
for Benin City but no archeology for the
from the 12th 12th century and also at
Kerman that's the beauty of this the
swiss excavations going back to 6,000 as
they're starting to pick out the early
parts of the city and they're finding
that the city just kind of blew up in
size from a model that was already that
was already there okay so unless lesson
2 is African cities grow organically and
not to some Near Eastern template again
remember it's the earlier archaeologists
who were digging to a Near Eastern
template and they're not finding cities
and they're not finding the true
diversity of cities because of those
blinders that they came to the to that
story with so finally how should see say
look at the cities hinter internet
should CeeCee's definition of the city
include rural relations well we have
this idea that there's a
there should be a dichotomy between
urban dwellers and rural dwellers
because of a very very European concept
and one of the the verifying urban
historians Spira cough-cough was talking
about in the case of siena one of the
italian cities that he excavated a that
he studied that a well-governed city is
separated by a wall from his countryside
so chaos is now in this country sight
wilderness is out in the countryside
order and and laws are behind the cities
now that's simplistic of course but
again it's one of these conceptions that
we brought from our end from the
innovation is part of the intellectual
baggage that we brought from the
nineteenth twentieth century to the
Soviet study of cities and I would
assert that's one of the reasons why we
haven't recognized really what was going
on with African African cities so let's
look at the hinterland here we're going
to go to the middle Niger so here's the
Niger River and one of its tributaries
right at the meeting of the tributaries
is Jenny the town that I started with
and the older town that goes back to 500
BC called Jenny Jenny Jenny Timbuktu is
on the Niger River and actually Gao is
right about there as we do city as we do
survey from Jenny to Timbuktu up into
the Sahara down the hinterland of
Timbuktu and following all those paleo
channels up into the Sarah particularly
in this area right here which is where I
first encountered al-qaeda it's one why
I can't excavate it at my site right now
but that will change I will get back to
my to my site but that's very we're
finding thousands and thousands not just
cities but city clusters and I will show
you why I make that that distinction but
just to give you an idea we think now
geomorphological II that the middle
Niger so this is this is what the middle
of Niger might have been maybe as late
as the 1st millennium BC but certainly
third millennia
BC this was an area of annual flooding
so basically a flood a very extensive
floodplain 2,000 BC at least a hundred
and seventy thousand square kilometers
command middle Niger much shrunk 55
thousand square kilometers but compare
that to the annually flooded areas of
Mesopotamia and and Egypt so it's in
some ways amazing that earlier colonial
period archaeologists didn't go to this
very large floodplain very wealthy
floodplain wealthy and stock and but
also in in in grain and why did they
didn't imagine that these mounds that
they saw topping up about the waters
with current and poachers weren't cities
as well but there was again one of these
blocks these into intellectual blocks so
that's that's the middle niger right
right now okay so this is the mound of
jenny general it's a kilometer
north-south why about 800 meters seven
meters high and I've been working there
since 1970 77 and this is what we do we
put big holes this is 6 meters by 10
meters this is one of my Molly encode
co-directors I get a crew of about 60
people most are so remember when I
talked about Gertrude Cade and Thompson
and the backfield piles here are our
backfield piles I would challenge anyone
to find a single pot search in my back
field pile because we we do screen
excavation techniques have has changed
changed a bit but we dig so you see all
the layers we dig layer by layer by
layer by layer so this this repartee no
to we're right about at the time of
Christ that took eight months to
excavate and we've got another metre and
a half two and a half meters to get to
about five 500 it's going to take us two
months just to backfill with a reduced
crew but just to backfill these these
holes so at this point I've put 28 of
these holes into the town
Jenny Channel but I joke about putting
telephone booths into this town that's
town the tell is so massive that even a
6 by 10 looks warped by the by the size
so what do we found number one no king
we certainly went in in the 70s
expecting to find a sad little expecting
to find find moderates no hierarchy we
expected to find some kind of reflection
of a hierarchical state like community
which is not to say that they're not
making high-value commodities so from
about four hundred eighty four hundred
to about six hundred about seventeen
percent of the pottery all the pottery
that's that's made has fugitive colors
so in other words the pot is is fired
and then they paint that the colors on
it it's like the Delft where you can't
use it all of that pottery is evenly
distributed amongst all of the houses
houses a pastoris houses of fishermen
houses of of blacksmiths not to say that
there wasn't some kind of a distribution
of wealth unequal distribution of wealth
but not on the order now certainly we
had expected
certainly we expected to find some kind
of a king some kind of advance chief and
to this point we haven't so now trot out
the standard joke if the next time I get
to Jenny Genoa and put it in one of
those holes and we come down on the
chief then I have to burn all of the
articles I've ever written I have to rip
up my thirteen books and commit suicide
because I basically have committed my
career to this idea that there's an
alternative to having a a city city
without without an adult so these little
dots represent the different different
units that we put in that these are
boreholes kind of just to give us an
idea of what the what the idea what the
stratigraphy is like but each of these
represent a different excavation from a
different season
if you've ever played whack-a-mole just
imagine here you're pushing this is not
proportionally horizontal and vertically
but each of the vertical you were
pushing the excavations going
meticulously through these the middle
stratigraphy at these different parts of
the mound in order to try to sample the
different parts of the of the of the
community so in other words if you're
hierarchically inclined you're going to
look for the the center Bowl you're
going to look for the palace you're
going to look for the temple if you
think something else is going on that's
a more diverse population then you've
got to do something something like like
this get a better sample of what's
what's going what's going on but it is a
classic tell you can see this trick of
your feet here this classic tale like in
in mess opinion Tammy a build up in the
same way people would go out into the
floodplain dig up the mud the alluvium
make their bricks bring it on to the
lawn into the town and with the rains it
only gets about 750 millimeters of rain
a year but in very short rainy season so
how is this melt in about 20 years they
melt people abandon them when they come
back to occupy that area they just
raised the area and and built on top of
it they want to be above the annual
floods so the higher that can beat them
so it's a classic
tell likely find in Mesopotamia but this
is this is what this is our excavation
technique this is my hell's angel found
him
reformed him by bringing him out over to
West Africa the most meticulous
excavator I've ever worked with
but Carol is near an archaeological
treasure anyone want to guess what this
is this feature here archaeologists love
these it's a latrine why do
archaeologists love latrines because
people bury their secrets in latrines we
know that when we find we find newest
latrines so just a couple of shots of
the of the exit this is BALCO sue who's
been it was my Foreman for 20 no 30 to 2
years at this point can x-ray better
than then I can so some of the burials
our neighbor girl is showing one of the
the gold earrings that we that we found
from about 800 BC have a number of these
statuettes and there's a certain
tradition art historical tradition that
says if you have terracotta statuette
production there has to be centralized
production there has to be a king
there's no evidence whatsoever that
there was a king or any kind of
centralized production great variety of
these things I understand on Friday that
you're going to their Art Gallery in the
Africa floor the second floor you'll see
a number of looted statuettes but we've
we've we were finding them as well now
we do have a city wall and one would say
oh then there had to be defense and and
strife and you have to have a king to
organize the defense of the cities
there's no evidence whatsoever as
opposed to the Senegal where I excuse me
where there's plenty of evidence for
rape pillage burning and all those all
those things that archeologists have a
certain skill to find no evidence
whatsoever in the 1500 year progression
of Jennie Jenna this is probably a
revetment to keep the the floodwater
sort of the high annual flood from
flooding into the town into the town
itself one of the things we do see is
advanced craftsmanship when we kind of
run through these so right from the very
beginning we have iron that's actually
not iron it's true steel is 0.3 percent
and purposely made steel the three point
three percent carbon steel Europe of
course doesn't have that unde until 1854
with the Bessemer process so they had
essentially discovered the Bessemer
process
this is from about 300 BC this is one of
the furnaces haven't cleared it out yet
but there's a Anti chamber for
controlling basically controlling the
carbon monoxide and the and the carbon
content of the air coming into the into
the chamber and we have a whole black
this is about 800 AD the whole
blacksmith's actually a workshop with
smithing furnaces one two three there's
one of my beloved latrines right side
over right outside of the and right here
it's a little bit hard to see there's a
male-female statuette pair buried into
the into the wall so I'm much more
inclined to say that these statuettes
are not part of a state religion but
they're familiar they're household gods
and goddesses that are part of part of
the different groups occupying that
buying the town
so here's Jenny Jenna here but you see
it's not alone now three kilometers away
is Jenny and there's the mosque but you
can see the waters are coming down
everything that's green here is our rice
fields but you can see these other tells
popping up above the above the waters so
surrounding Jenny and Jenny
jeno are 72 other tells within a four
kilometer radius and they're occupied at
the same time and I'm arguing that they
function as a cluster that they function
as an assemble city so here's another
shot Jenny Jenna so shallow swamp
fishermen exclusively occupied this site
here
blacksmiths occupied this site this site
this is kind of a Lobel site here no I
no evidence of any kind of occupation
but there are lots and lots of
statuettes lots and lots of what we
think are altars so it's kind of a
ritual area now you would think why not
on the Mesopotamian model all
agglomerate come in together build a
city we'll all around yourself rather
than having this clustered or
organization well that's that's I think
the value of of digging different kinds
of cities because you get get to ask
those different questions
the satellite site certainly changed
through time so here's a blacksmith site
once it's abandoned in the 12th century
then it's taken over as a cemetery so
these are burial urns they're between
one and five people crammed into each of
each of these of these urns so very
laborious to try to figure out what's
going on about five minutes okay that'll
work very laborious so every every mound
here in red has at least one excavation
22 at Jenny jeno and all of the mounds
have been thoroughly surface surveyed we
collect the material to try to get an
idea at least at the end of occupation
what was going on at that site here's
basically what's what's what's going on
there's very little oral tradition
except for this site so blacksmiths
living in town today said oh yes that's
our ancestors sites they were deepwater
fishermen and blacksmiths at the same
time that's very very rare and the
blacksmith thing was probably more to
make a cult power then then to do to
make iron but so in the few cases where
we have present oral tradition kind of
fits with this idea that was more or
less exclusive occupation by different
occupation groups at the different types
so we go back to tell Brock and the tell
Brock of the period of the Harvard
excavations and Jason or and he started
off excavating the town itself kind of
all into a poor model and and finishing
up with David and Jo Jo Ann Oates but
then he starts to look at he goes to the
hinterland and he starts to surface
collect and he starts to find
collections of or higher densities of
absurds from different periods and then
he does the modern kind of chemical
analyses that we can do of the
archaeological soils archaeological
soils have a lot of phosphorous in them
because they're cattle and humans that
are being all the - all the time so it's
one it's one of the ways that
Scandinavian archaeologists find
temporary camps of Vikings
they may have been there for only one
season or only a couple but they're
peeing there all the time so it's just
they pick it up with with with with the
phosphate phosphate analysis so Jason
has a very very different sense of
what's going on at that at or then David
and and and Joe so we go to China very
very quickly Shandong Province per place
that shouldn't have had outside of the
Central Basin of the of the Yellow River
shouldn't have had early cities we've
got this very very early city 2800 BC in
the Neolithic not even in the Bronze Age
and sure enough it's one of these
assembled cities it's all there's no
city wall no central focus of the city
which is going to be the signature of
the Chinese city later on but different
crafts places locales that function
certainly the argument that an Underhill
from here it's making is that they
function as a as a city so lesson 3 how
does C say define the city
it's a working it's a grunt definition
of a of a city of an ancient city it's
one that archeologists can did deal with
a large settlement not saying how large
with a heterogeneous population we don't
have to specify how heterogeneous or
heterogeneous tapped by a by a by a by a
king that provides a variety of services
and manufacturers to a larger hinterland
those are the things that archaeologists
can find we can find the city and
hierarchy of cities small towns a medium
towns small towns and villages that go
along a continuum of you'll find
blacksmiths probably in every kind of
settlement in West West Africa but
you'll only find Goldsmith's in the in
the cities but when you find the gold
from the town in the villages you know
they have some kind of a relationship so
when you take that kind of a definition
it looks very very different then our
old way of looking at at cities so what
has the African experience told us about
cities writ large
first of all is you may have kings and
Kings are a nice thing to have when you
have enemies from pounding on on your
gates but you don't necessarily have to
have kings and those manifestations of
Kings like city walls instead of those
of the things that that were our proxies
for the despotic organization of society
don't necessarily have to be found the
bad part of course of despotism and of
Kings is that there are Kings are always
going off from raiding other cities and
bringing back the slaves so remember
when you if there's a tendency to to
glorify ancient cities much of the labor
that was involved in producing the
goodies were produced by unfree unfree
labor Rome and Athens not accepted not
accepted I'm not saying that there
wasn't slavery in Jenna Jenna but we
have absolutely no evidence of that from
the oral traditions from the Arab
sources or from the archaeology question
ok almost almost almost there the city
is not isolated you need to understand
the hinterland and it won't do just to
build it to dig the the palace structure
and and that and the temple structure if
you believe something is though else is
going on with the population you have to
have an a sampling excavation strategy
that will show you show you that so why
study African cities at very beginning I
talked about this idea of original
civilizations only six where he had
urbanism showing up without any evidence
of sort of cross-pollination now I know
this for many archeologists this is a
way outdated idea but many of these
issues are taken from very recent
textbooks high school textbooks this
being one kind of showing what they're
talking about they Andean civilization
Mesoamerican civilization we accept that
they were original urban civilizations
no no the holder thought that there is
cross pollenization we just don't get
that and you
wait well yeah so one two three four
five North China six diffusion so the
older idea was anything good you find
out at Southeast Asia is diffused out of
China anything good that you find in
West Africa is diffused out of Egypt and
we're just not finding that not one
Egyptian seance beat not one finishing
coin not one Roman coin in all of the
excavations that we've that we've that
we that we've done so just to end up
this is the cover of another one of the
textbooks again the six civilizations so
to be facetious I think we can change
that cover to at least add one more
original original Civ civilization I
would say probably many many more in the
rest of sub-saharan Africa and in
Southeast Asia
and certainly we know from some of the
graduate students here on the Amazonian
slip site of the of the the Andean slip
site of the Amazonian site thank you
very much
[Applause]